[Music]
we always say around here
that
personal finance is 80 behavior it's
only 20 head knowledge so i stumbled
into the fact
backed into the fact 20 years ago in
this 30-year journey
that
if you don't have your marriage
working on the same page
the chances of you becoming wealthy and
getting out of debt are very low
it's worse than that
if you aren't controlling your behaviors
your maturity level is not increasing
emotionally
spiritually
your ability to build wealth and hold on
to it
is
ridiculously low and actual data points
to that the extreme of that is
i have worked in the financial crisis
world now off and on or you know
indirectly directly for 30 years
and 100
of the addicts
that i have ever met
end up broke
it's just a matter of when
they either break away from the
addiction
and the behaviors associated with it or
they end up broke because the addiction
eats their life
alive from the inside out it eats up all
their relationships it eats up all their
money it eats up their career and their
ability to make money it eats up
everything eventually it it takes hold
and it is the
god that demands minute by minute day by
day worship and steals your life from
you
addictions are the extreme of
misbehavior
but 100 of the misbehavior whatever we
want to call that if you want to uh call
it an old christian word we'll call it
sin
if you want to call it just
things that don't help you personally
that are harming you personally but feel
good in the moment then you get in all
kinds of garbage here
and so and what we've seen is an
explosion of those things
whether they're to the addiction level
or not
uh because of our access to the internet
and the resulting uh industry explosions
around uh gambling
online gambling number two addiction now
in the world
approaching number one
and destroying families for obvious
reasons destroying their finances for
obvious reasons
uh and uh because it is the ultimate in
arrogance that you think you're gonna
win and uh number one addiction uh porn
yep and online porn i mean when i was a
little kid porn was a was a playboy
hidden under a rock in the woods exactly
you know
uh
and are under somebody's some kid's
mattress in the neighborhood that's not
porn anymore no and every playboy ever
printed is on somebody's cell phone
right by their bedside table right well
and it's boring compared to right yeah
uh the other stuff now i mean it's just
bizarre and let me just tell you guys if
you don't know this
it's the number one addiction and more
money is spent on pornography now in
america than all professional sports
including nascar combined
more than spent on nfl tickets
nba tickets
anything added together and we know what
it's doing to their lives we know it's
not just being approved
that's not the point the point is
there's a behavior mechanism here that
is being destroyed in people's lives
and so when you pull up on the internet
we do research here all the time on the
internet because we're always utilizing
the internet for marketing and for
connecting to you guys for good stuff
but
by far 5x the number one search is porn
yep
by far
and the first 50 things that are
searched on the internet
almost none of them have anything to do
with you winning right are you doing
anything you doing it they're all you
controlling you joe biden donald trump
yeah misspellings of joe biden made the
top 50.
that's funny i don't care who you are uh
the uh uh you know porn triple x free
porn nfl scores yeah gambling scores uh
nba scores
uh in a uh
college football scores nothing wrong
watching football nothing wrong with it
you know with some of this but but you
it's all about you escaping somewhere
watching someone else be successful
that's right i will never forget i went
to see a
i forgot the movie it was a jazz movie
james probably knows what it is uh la la
land yeah and i went and saw the movies
beautiful movies it was great with me
and my wife and i walked out and i was
walking towards our car in the parking
lot and i thought
i just spent 30 bucks in two hours of my
life to watch another couple
go have a romantic
arc in jazz clubs and dancing when i
could have just taken my wife dancing
and i never forget thinking i'm
outsourcing why don't i go get a group
of guys to go play basketball why do i
pay money to watch other people play i
don't even know them why would i put
another man's jersey on my back that
doesn't make sense get some guys to go
play softball and i realized in on the
way to my car out of that park out of
that movie theater
i'm outsourcing my entire life
pornography is just an outsource of
intimacy opioids is an outsourcing right
it just keeps going and going and going
and at some point we have to plug back
in or the teeter-totter hits for us
right the economy collapses we're going
to stare each other in the face and be
like oh hey i haven't seen you in a
while right we're gonna have to deal
with it at some point and man if we
could plug back into our own lives man
what would that be like yeah don't watch
a fishing show go fishing right
yeah go fishing don't go watch your
golfing don't watch don't watch golf as
a princess please just in general don't
watch golf but go outside go play go go
play golf go play i know you suck at it
i do too go plug them i'm not gonna go
play off i'm not gonna go i suck i'm
saying i'm talking to the people out
there you're really good i'm not that
good but they they i mean i just learned
how to play but uh you know like it's
this but go learn how to play juice
down do something you know
instead of spending eight million
dollars
on a
5 000 square inch television yeah put a
golf simulator in your basement yes
which by the way one of our guys here
did the other day built it out himself
wow so the point being guys you you you
think you can separate these behaviors
or these misbehaviors
from your lack of success in your money
and your career and you can't they're
the cause it's all intertwined
they're the cause that's how it works
so you're not gonna win if you keep uh
misbehaving i'll just leave it at that
if you keep running from your life yeah
don't outsource
wow that's good i like that that's a
good word don't
this is the ramsey shop